El joven alcalde de enea tiene mucho que
hacer una ciudad bajo ocupación rusa
residentes en el exilio y una central
nuclear como espada de damocles es la
prioridad de la inteligencia ucraniana
que cree que Moscú está dispuesto a
provocar allí un accidente para congelar
la línea de frente Hasta qué punto
permitirán los ocupantes que los
empleados garanticen la seguridad del
emplazamiento porque los soldados viven
y duermen allí y tienen una base militar
con munición en el lugar nadie sabe qué
órdenes les darán y cuáles Serán las
consecuencias solo podemos esperar que
todo salga bien lo que más le preocupa
es el futuro de los empleados ucranianos
que han conservado su empleo
la presión sobre ellos es alta algunos
de los empleados van a trabajar unas
2500 personas la mayoría de ellos
tuvieron que firmar contratos bajo
presión con rosatón la empresa rusa
otros no querían firmar contratos pero
los ocupantes tienen más remedio que
dejarles trabajar porque no pueden
sustituirlas
[Música]
organizó este centro para que los
exiliados
pudieran encontrar ayuda la mayoría de
los hombres que están aquí son antiguos
técnicos de la central
como no preocuparse Estoy preocupado
porque es mi ciudad ya hay bastantes
problemas pero Confío en los empleados
Conozco muchos de ellos lucharán porque
viven allí pero con estos lunáticos
dirigiendo el sitio Perdón por la
expresión todo es posible
la destrucción de la presa de no bajas
no les tranquiliza para ellos es
inimaginable Pero así son las cosas su
central eléctrica se ha convertido en
una arma del Arsenal ruso en Ucrania